[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando ero piccolo volevo crescere
volevo diventare un adolescenza anche
perché mi ero già immaginato tutto era
pazzesco
ricky a scuola superiore anche se
chiaramente a quest'età non sapeva
ancora all'indirizzo perché poi come
tutti i bambini da piccolo volevo fare
un sacco di cose da grande dal
giornalista l'astronauta immaginavo la
prima vera storia d'amore con la
compagna più carina del liceo e poi sono
un sacco di altre cose
richiede patente ricky il sabato sera in
discoteca con gli amici
in realtà poi quando sono diventato
adolescente mi sono reso conto che non
era proprio l'età così bella che mi
aspettavo perché ho capito che stavo
iniziando con la scusa di essere
adolescente a giustificare un sacco di
comportamenti dai vestiti alla sigaretta
puoi rispondere male i miei genitori
perché in fondo era un adolescente ed
era normale fare quelle cose lo facevano
tutti doveva andare così
che poi che poi in realtà c'è stato un
momento ben preciso in cui ho proprio
capito che l'adolescenza è una vera
fregatura ed era il primo giorno di
scuola superiore quando il professore mi
chiese che cosa vuoi fare da grande ecco
io mi sono sentito avete presente quando
ci alziamo da un posto e dimentichiamo
il telefono e non finisce fuori lo
cerchiamo dappertutto il cuore si ferma
e sentiamo una sorta di vuoto dentro di
noi ma io davanti a quella domanda a 15
anni stavo perdendo molto molto di più
stavo perdendo i miei sogni perché la
lista delle cose che volevo fare da
bambino era sparita e resta in silenzio
perché non sapevo cosa rispondere al
professore ma la cosa ancora più buffa è
che mi fa sorridere anche adesso è che
quando passai lo sguardo per l'imbarazzo
perché non riuscivo a guardare in viso
il professore imi occhi calderoso una
frase una frase che la scritta nel
diario perché lo stavo sfogliando e mi
ha molto colpito diceva l'adolescenza è
un brufolo che ti viene nel cuore in
quel preciso momento in quel preciso
momento ho capito che questo non potevo
trattarlo come tutti gli altri due
folletti perché da qui dentro altrimenti
sarei scoppiato anche io
iniziare a pensare che ci fosse qualcosa
di sbagliato in me con i miei genitori
che non erano stati in grado di impedire
questo cambiamento non c'era niente di
sbagliato in ma non c'è niente di
sbagliato in noi adolescenti
l'adolescenza è stata inventata e oggi
ve ne darò le prove oltre a farvi
scoprire una profezia si lo so cosa
state pensando ma come si è inventato
questo su questo palco che l'adolescenza
è stata inventata
beh l'ho pensato anch'io quando l'ho
sentita dire pensate da un mio amico che
era a pranzo da me e mia mamma che è
sempre un po invadente e gli ha chiesto
come stanno andando i tuoi anni
adolescenziali e lui rispose tutte
cavolate che ci spacciano l'adolescenza
non esiste l'abbiamo inventata perché
dal momento in cui ti convincono che tu
l'adolescente subirei tutti quei
cambiamenti
tu sarai un adolescente io gli ho riso
in faccia
eppure queste teorie mi incuriosiva e
questo mi ha spinto a fare delle
ricerche
insomma cerca ricerca trova non trova mi
sono imbattuto in un blog sociologico
images e ho trovato questo grafico
questo è un grafico che documenta la
nascita della nozione di adolescenza ed
è stata elaborata da un docente
universitario del maryland philippe
cohen
chiaramente si vede questa linea blu
crescere crescere sempre di più a
partire dal novecento perché questi sono
gli anni in cui vengono pubblicati i
primi studi pubblici sull'adolescenza ma
esattamente cosa ci faceva questo punti
non ho lo vedete intorno agli anni 70
più in alto di tutti quasi fiero della
sua posizione ha conservato avuto questo
picco ora più di te gli occhi
immaginatevi di non essere su una
poltrona di questo teatro confido nella
vostra immaginazione
siete invece negli stati uniti d'america
anni 70 secondo me sapete fare molto di
più
boom economico immaginatevelo tendete
l'orecchio ascoltate ascoltati i rumori
della gente che compra in maniera
sfrenata qualsiasi cosa c'è la fila
c'ero prima io ciò che dici mi stai
superando televisioni a go go hanno
usate hanno usate l'odore della
necessità di rendere il consumismo
ancora più consumismo il chiedete come
il cervello lavora fa cercando la
risposta ecco ci siete creando
appositamente una fetta di persone che
consumasse
senza produrre in modo da tenere la
domanda più alta dell'offerta come
facevano a consumare senza produrre con
la scuola alzando l'obbligo scolastico
proprio in questi anni sempre di più
ve lo riassume in un pensiero se sei uno
studente non lavori non lavorando non
produci non producendo se solamente
costretto a consumare anni settanta
teenagers l'adolescenza stata inventata
e le sue problematiche sono causate
dalla società che poi a proposito di
problematiche ma chi se l'è inventata
quel maledetto giorno che noi
adolescenti dobbiamo avere queste crisi
d'identità
erick erickson psicoanalista e psicologo
tedesco vissuto e torniamo sempre lì
alla fine negli stati uniti d'america e
gli disse oltre migliaia e migliaia di
studi che fece che per diventare un
adulto fedele responsabile impegnato
ogni adolescente doveva necessariamente
non ci poteva far niente necessariamente
passare attraverso una crisi d'identità
ma margaret mead non la pensava così
margaret mead era un antropologo
americana è invece un viaggio in samoa
che si trova in polinesia nell'oceano
pacifico e andò qui per studiare le
problematiche adolescenziali filmati
stupita nel vedere che gli adolescenti
in samoa non erano tormentati da tutte
queste problematiche tipiche della
società occidentale
anzi vi vivono l'adolescenza in modo
sereno capite quanto influisce il
modello sociale differente in tutto
questo
le recenti noi adolescenti siamo sempre
di più percepiti come un problema ma
d'altronde questo voi lo sapete non è un
fatto nuovo per esempio durante questa
mia ricerca mi è capitato di imbattermi
in una sorta di profezia e mi ha molto
colpito perché la molto molto antica era
di un poeta greco esiodo e risaliva
pensate a ben 2mila 700 39 anni fa ed
era così bella ma così bella che ve la
voglio leggere anche perché non la
voglio sbagliare sentite non c'è più
alcuna speranza per l'avvenire del
nostro paese
se la gioventù di oggi prenderà il
potere di domani poiché questa gioventù
è insopportabile senza ritegno
pericolosa già allora già 2.739 anni fa
i ragazzi di questo eterno considerati
un problema ma c'è una cosa da dire che
il tempo passa e le società cambiano
cambiano i costumi i popoli la lingua le
innovazioni
eppure uno dei problemi sociali più
importanti da oltre 2500 anni è rimasto
lo stesso i giovani quando chiaramente
l'adolescenza non esisteva
poi siamo diventati noi solo che ora
lasciatemi dire che questo problema è
diventato più urgente molto più urgente
il mercatino reso l'adolescenza liquida
come l'acqua come qualsiasi liquido che
si adatta alle forme di un contenitore e
sono loro i mercati e recipienti i
contenitori che la plasmano la modellano
decidono in che forma si deve presentare
in che quantità
e noi ne adolescenti sempre di più siamo
schiavi schiavi destinati a costruire
piramidi del progresso basato sul
consumo perché quella particolare maglia
quel particolare vestito quella
particolare canzone quelle particolari
scarpe e ci rendono adolescenti davvero
quasi senza queste cose non lo fossimo
perché dobbiamo avere delle cose che ci
permettono di etichettarci anche perché
in un mondo fatto di solitudine in un
mondo fatto di solitudine andare
controcorrente fa paura
ed è così che dalla paura del buio che
avevo da piccolino andavo da mamma per
dormire ho iniziato ad avere paura di
questa solitudine e come quando entri in
un labirinto soltanto che non c'è più
non avevo più fiducia negli amici perché
ero talmente attorniato da amici
virtuali che quelli reali erano sempre
di meno e abbiamo iniziato a comunicarci
immagine like cuore rosso aggiorna al
feed
ma nella vita reale non ci sono e laiche
non c'è un pollicione in su non c'è un
pollice in giù non ci sono soltanto le
foto in cui vini bene e che vuoi far
vedere ci sei tu tu stesso in qualsiasi
momento anche quelli che non vorresti
far vedere continuamente esposto allo
sguardo delle altre persone che non
aspettano altro che un altro mancanza
benvenuti nel mondo dell'immagine
benvenuti nel mondo della solitudine
questa è la scritta che si trova nella
porta per entrare nel nostro mondo
dobbiamo uscire a chiuderla a chiave e
buttarla via
anche perché contemporaneamente noi
adolescenti stiamo vivendo un altro un
altro paradosso quello della velocità
nel senso che vogliamo tutto è
immediatamente anche quando c'è bisogno
di aspettare
del resto se vi dico come avviene una
semplice chat tra due adolescenti
avviene così è on line il mio messaggio
dopamina risposta dopamina il viola
risposta al messaggio ulteriore dopamina
ultimo accesso no aspetta è tornato
online
ricevo la risposta alla risposta del
messaggio tutto questo in quanto un
minuto 2 forse dobbiamo imparare ad
avere il giusto ritmo e avere la
capacità di attendere perché stiamo
correndo troppo e troppo velocemente
stiamo crescendo imparando a pensare a
lavorare a riflettere alla maniera di un
fast food ospita proprio noi italiani
proprio noi italiani che siamo legati al
concetto del buono e del bello e del ben
fatto sappiamo che il cibo buono non si
trova nei fast food che i pensieri le
idee innovative non si trova in un
eccesso di velocità dobbiamo abbassare
il fornello perché stiamo bruciando
e nella velocità incredibile nella
velocità ci dimentichiamo di mettere
dentro le spezie il sale il pepe
peperoncino l'olio
mettiamoci le dentro di un po di sapore
a questi pensieri cuciniamo li bene
dannazione perché ne abbiamo bisogno
capite che alimenterà adolescente non è
stato così facile
dobbiamo cambiare
ce lo dicono guardate da 2500 anni ma io
credo che oggi nella società attuale sia
davvero davvero urgente e se non l'avete
ancora capito però scrivo con una
formula f è uguale a r più ci più di
moltiplicato a al quadrato
la f f di felicità perché ce ne siamo
totalmente dimenticati perché noi
adolescenti ci siamo dimenticati delle
bellissime esperienze che questa età ci
regala incredibile come tutto questo
tempo siamo stati fermi seduti a girarci
i pollici mentre la felicità correva e
andava avanti avanti
se guardate che se lo non ci muoviamo a
rincorrerla lo stacco sarà troppo troppo
grande e non ce la faremo più per
ottenerla devo sommare tre componenti la
rd ritmo ovvero l'ordinamento di
qualsiasi movimento
dobbiamo imparare ad avere la capacità
di attendere dobbiamo fermarci sostarci
prendere fiato ma perché il mondo è più
veloce di noi e noi non possiamo pensare
di sfidarsi in una gara di corsa perché
perderemo poi lacci lacci della
creatività perché incredibile ci siamo
dimenticati anche di questa e stiamo
perdendo i petali dei nostri talenti
mentre volo non volano via noi cerchiamo
di a fermarli ma ce l'abbiamo ce li
avete semplicemente nessuno ci ha mai
spiegato come utilizzarli perché sin da
piccole incredibile sin da piccoli siamo
stati educati alla correzione
dell'errore e non su cosa sappiamo fare
meglio e va a finire che tu ci credi
infine devo sommarlo a di che sta per
differenza generazionale ovvero guardate
la più grande opportunità che noi
millennials possiamo avere perché non
c'è cosa peggiore nel vedere quasi una
gara una gara fra le generazioni a chi
ha fatto chi farà meglio le generazioni
passate ci hanno costruito gli strumenti
che noi sappiamo usare molto molto
meglio di loro
e loro lo sanno pertanto ci dovrebbe
essere un aiuto reciproco una
collaborazione perché soltanto in questo
modo
soltanto in questo modo potremo scrivere
l'alfabeto del futuro tutto questo devo
moltiplicarlo per a per al quadrato che
sta per la di atteggiamento
ma perché al quadrato perché il
moltiplicatore più importante è il
moltiplicatore più importanti di questa
formula senza giusto atteggiamento
continueremo vivere terrorizzati dalla
paura del futuro
la paura della solitudine dobbiamo
imparare a vivere il presente a guardare
il futuro con gli occhi del presente
se vogliamo vincere questa angoscia e
poi dobbiamo anche imparare a rimanere
soli ma avere cura della nostra
solitudine farla diventare una
possibilità piacevole per poi cercare il
contatto
a proposito di contatto lo abbiamo
lasciato totalmente stare della
connessione con gli altri giorno dopo
giorno perché dobbiamo diventare meno
social meno social ma più socievoli il
risultato di questa formula spetta
soltanto a voi cercate la che ne so
mentre state aspettando il trump e non
arriva o mentre siete entrambi siete
dimenticati le cuffiette mentre sei
tempo nell'ora di matematica con il
libro aperto di annoiato a morte
scrivete la fotografia tra non mi
interessa non mi interessa cosa ne
facciate ma dobbiamo dobbiamo risolverlo
perché credo che cambiare se un nostro
dovere per diventare sì oggi migliori di
ieri ma domani migliori di oggi credo e
ve lo dico con grande convinzione che
questo cambiamento non sarà indolore
mi dispiace dirvelo ci costerà il
coraggio il coraggio di accendere la
luce e vedere finalmente finalmente
tutto quello che semplicemente abbiamo
ignorato perché molti di noi ce l'hanno
fatta
altri come me ci stanno provando ma la
cosa piu importante e della quale sono
completamente convinto è che molti di
voi ce la potrebbero fare
è questa la mia profezia
[Musica]
grazie